à l'entrée de la propriété
la mise en garde n'effraie personne la
cueillette des haricots verts bio a été
bonne et les paniers repartent bien
gardé c'est vous qui avait récolté et
c'est gratuit vous connaissez les
raisons bas pour cause de la plante
toxique on en avait pas peur non non non
puisqu'on a récolté à la main de qui a
pas eu de mélange avec la plante toxique
la nouvelle a fait l'effet d'une traînée
de poudre depuis plusieurs jours on
assiste à un ballet ininterrompu de
voitures dans la parcelle de 10 hectares
réservés la culture des haricots verts
bio lacker 80 personnes environ par jour
s'en donnent à coeur joie
on libère le champ de du monsieur et il
nous en fait profiter ses c'est super
c'est super ça fera le bonheur de la
famille des voisins des personnes qu'on
peut plus se déplacer c'est pour ne pas
être obligé de broyer ses 150 tonnes de
haricots verts bio que cet agriculteur a
dû faire ce choix prise à la gorge par
son acheteur une grosse firme qui a
rompu le contrat en cause la présence
d'une plante jugés toxiques la nature
un désherbage à la main et effet tout le
champ à la main puis éparpillés un mètre
carré par mètre carré un et après on est
passé sept à huit fois pour enlever les
natura qui pousse en permanence qui
pousse en permanence malgré toutes ces
précautions le couperet est tombé
le contrat stipulait 0 datura est bon
ils ont le ils prennent le parapluie il
se protège à 100% mais que nous on
travaille d'une matière vivante 1 le sol
la plante en plus le climat renoncer en
bio non ça non c'est une conviction que
j'ai un et si vous voulez après je pense
m'orienter un petit peu différemment sur
la façon de produire autre commercialisé
sur tout la cueillette à la ferme
l'agriculteur y songent désormais
convaincus que la datura va coloniser
les champs dont les dix prochaines
années